from timcast.com online legal Fund in
support of Daniel Penny reaches 2
million dollars the law firm managing
the fundraiser said any funds left over
will be donated to a mental health
advocacy program in New York City
personally I think it should go to
Daniel penny so he can buy himself a
nice car but the story is by Hannah
Hannah Claire bremelo who's sitting
right here so what happened oh hey so I
actually feel like we should throw you
into this but as we all know uh Daniel
Penny surrendered to New York uh law
enforcement on Friday he was released a
hundred thousand dollar Bond and his Law
Firm set up this gives and go which has
surpassed two million dollars I think on
Saturday or Sunday night it was 1
million it just keeps ramping up since I
wrote this story it was at like 2
million eighty thousand when I wrote
this and it's 2.3 now so he has
generated a lot of support from people
uh some notable figures including uh
Vivek ramaswamy he gave ten thousand
dollars Kid Rock who said that he does
not like Alvin braggy 5000 andara our
very own Tim pool gave twenty thousand
dollars yeah I thought bad I also
messaged him and asked for a comment and
he said nah so I guess did I say nah oh
I didn't really professional
relationship I didn't I didn't I woke up
this morning and I was reading more news
about Daniel penny and I was looking at
these pictures and I was saying all last
week like this guy should not go to jail
this is a good person who was doing the
right thing and I had like Nuance bro
tweeted at me he was like bro you went
to New York and DC and Austin recently
and you're telling people not to go to
cities and I was like yes I've talked
all about this and I started thinking
about it and I started uh someone made
the argument that they they can't leave
the city because they were divorced and
if they leave it means abandoning their
kids to what's going on and if they stay
they can be there for their kids I was
like that's a really good point actually
not everybody can just leave and it's
not because of difficulty it's because
of legal restrictions and so I thought
about that I'm like if somebody gets a
divorce their kids are stuck in the city
leaving will be the worst possible thing
they could do and that means staying in
the fire is basically someone huddling
over their children to protect them from
the Flames I can respect that so I need
to rethink this and then I thought about
a few other things for one I do feel bad
being the only person not stepping up to
help a guy who did the right thing and
that was like the most obvious thing so
then I'm like I should I should probably
just donate to this guy like it's not
about anything outside of anything else
let's just keep it to the one individual
dude who did the right thing and
probably needs our help yeah simply put
but then I then I thought when I was
looking at it and I was I was like you
know I saw Vivek gave 10 grand I saw
some Anonymous donors gave a bunch of
money and I was like
if I had just donated last week I
probably could have Justified and I'll
throw a guy a couple Grand but now
considering I spent the past week being
like nah I'm not going to lay home
button I'm not I better I better make it
something big I was thinking about
you know what what I could give so I I
said twenty thousand dollars
um and I kind of thought that there are
many more people who could do more than
that and I often complain about how rich
people aren't doing enough to win the
culture War name names too about who
should be giving more money yeah why not
Phil's got some ideas about who could be
giving me aging Mr boring Mr Jerry
reborn
has raised the challenge and no no I
didn't say anything about the deal we
have we have so many of your candy bars
here and we've been promoting Mr boring
please help this young man you are a
wealthy individual that's all that is
but I did say this morning I challenge
anybody who can to give more than I did
because I know they can there's a few
other things to consider it's not first
and foremost I'm like this guy shouldn't
go to prison it's unfortunate Jordan
nearly lost his life I'm sad about this
I know the guy had criminal convictions
I know he'd been arrested and he's been
accused of really bad things but I I
also
you know I I don't I don't want people
to lose their lives especially if
they're homeless hungry and they're
unwell the left has taken the stance
that Jordan Neely was unwell therefore
he didn't deserve to die and I'm kind of
like I don't care if you're well or
unwell if you attack people threaten
people and he did Witnesses said he was
issuing death threats yeah and you don't
deserve to die but someone's got to stop
you from hurting people so ultimately
what I'll say is this it's not just
about Daniel Petty but first and
foremost it is but after that
it's about winning in the cities I
thought about if we don't win the right
to self-defense in the cities it comes
to our doorstep next so let's keep it
over there the next thing I thought was
if we do win much like Anheuser-Busch it
negates the effort from the left in
their pressure campaign with the left
going out riding and smashing things up
and fighting with cops let's send a
message that their protests mean nothing
and this man will not face a minute
Behind Bars because we will win yeah
yeah well I'm just just to pop in here I
think the fundraiser is pretty
indicative of how the rest of the
country feels he his fundraiser is over
two million dollars and I think Jordan
Neely's uh I don't know whatever
contribution setup that he did but I
think it only raised about a hundred
thousand two hundred thousand so very
glad that it that um Daniel pennis has
gone over 2 million it's showing where
the pulse of the country is right now
yeah I mean one of the comments that I
saw on it when I wrote the story this
morning was someone saying I live in New
York I'm a democratic don't I'm not a
Christian but I had some very terrifying
interactions with Jordan Neely and
Daniel Penny does not deserve this I
mean I think it's interesting that
specifically Jordan early while it's sad
that he is deceased and obviously we
don't want anyone to experience violence
like this uh he has an established
criminal history the fact that people
were aware of who this was that he has
you know he punched some 60 year old
grandmother she broke her skull because
of it uh this isn't just like a random
attack from you know some Marine veteran
who's just decided no and this strikes a
chord with a lot of people I mean this
this is a scenario in which anybody
could be in that scenario it happens
every single day that there's a
psychopath on the train and you often
wonder what am I going to do if I have a
loved one or if I have a girlfriend next
to me you know am I going to be
prosecuted like Daniel Penny I mean but
that's exactly what they want they this
is an attack on self-defense and so they
want you to be able to submit to these
random Psychopaths that should be in
asylums Jordan Neely's GoFundMe has 134
273 dollars raised so I I think this
fundraiser is fine they want to raise
money for his funeral costs I think it's
sad the dude died I don't want anybody
to die this wasn't the case of some
political extremists who was seeking to
harm people like going to a school and
murdering children or anything like that
it was a guy who was just generally
unwell and was did was rejected like was
dejected rejected and uh and it's part
of social decay
I blame the Democrats for a lot of
what's happening these NIMBY policies
that have been going on for a long time
that I've personally experienced when I
work for non-profits but that's not for
the individual him nor for Daniel Penny
this dude didn't this shouldn't have
died but I gotta I gotta stop and just
say whatever the reason be you well or
unwell when you go into a confined space
and start threatening people saying
you'll take their lives if three people
are threatened by you that to the point
where they think they must subdue you
I mean that's it like you went you
aggressed you started this that being
said if people want to raise money for
this for this Man's family and
everything I think that's mighty fine I
think it's sad that you know there's
going to be costs associated with his
loss of life and I wish this this kind
of stuff didn't happen how do we solve
that problem it's not solved by locking
up Daniel Penny who was a victim in the
matter trying to save other people
it's definitely not um and the broader
political motivations
um really are just very gross because
most people if they're honest with
themselves when they really think about
if if they were in that situation if
they were in that train car they would
feel much better about him being
restrained than him running around and
and intimidating everyone on the on the
train and to say any differently is so
dishonest I've seen some people on the
left from some of the leftist shows
listening to the ridiculous things that
they say about this situation is it's
really stomach turning it is it's well
we had uh we had Lance from the surfs on
this show
and he kept playing this manipulative
game
was it proportional
did did uh does Jordan Neely's erratic
Behavior warrant being choked to death
and it's like but Daniel Penny wasn't
trying to choke him to death Daniel
Penny actually tried to save his life
one of them on video you can see Penny
and others try to save Jordan Neely
after subduing him one of the things
that I heard that really set me off and
and offended my sensibilities the most
um someone was saying that it was
Bourgeois to think that they should be
able to take the train without having to
experience that kind of intimidation it
was characterized as discomfort because
it was a an extremely
leftist-leaning person but it's it's not
only is it gross to think oh it's
Bourgeois to think that you should be
secure in your person right the very the
fun most fundamental property you have
is your own body and it's Bourgeois to
think that you should be secure in your
person first of all and second of all
this is the type of transportation that
people on the left are constantly saying
that we need more of they don't want go
ahead I think we've probably all been on
the subway in New Yorker in some major
city and like yes there are occasionally
people who are homeless who are not well
we're talking themselves whatever but
the fact that multiple people called
9-1-1 is unusual like if the New Yorkers
are so calm and chill about this whole
thing this must have really rattled them
if they see this every day and you're
not supposed to be offended by it the
fact that there were multiple calls to
9-1-1 before there was a confrontation
is indicative of a situation that is
abnormal even for people who are like
hey I'm not even gonna look at you we're
gonna pretend you're not here I'm just
gonna get on the train and go and and
this is going to Tim and mentioned
something else that this is going to tie
into but it's this this
idea on the left or actually this
perspective on the left that is so
detached from reality and you see it in
multiple Arenas right right now we're
talking about you know defense of your
own life and defense of your own you
know yourself to think that you don't
have that right to think that the state
should step in and put you in jail
because you had the audacity to try to
defend yourself and other people is it's
a terrible terrible attack on on
individual rates and I think that the
more we can do to shut it down the
better where we're the social workers
yeah I want to know I mean why weren't
they why weren't they there sooner to
your point why aren't people interested
if you're supposed to be used to this uh
every day isn't that sad that we would
live in humanity where you're watching
someone suffer a mental illness because
that's what we all agree on you're
nearly was extremely troubled mentally
ill uh and your reality is that you
think that we should just ignore it that
we should just pretend it's it's normal
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang with us live
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and become
a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time